[Musique]
je vois quand il donne par exemple une
femme vingt ans ou bien 15 à 10 ans un
plus haut mais ça c'est pour vous savez
quand même oui voilà le seul message que
je peux déjà dû aux autorités maliennes
vraiment lieu de revoir la condamnation
défend oui l'erreur humaine c'est vrai
nul n'est parfait dans la vie mais
vraiment qu'il revoie un peu la
condamnation défendre vallat
[Musique]
à
où
[Musique]
je pense que nous avons coulé
tout ça dans toutes ces filles mineures
que vous vous êtes dans la détention
elles font quelque chose elles font une
activité nous ne sont pas seulement un
centre de détention même sommes là
également pour rééduquer pour apprendre
ou de télé d'insultés quinzaine à tous
deux réunis afin de préparer leur
réinsertion dans la société
[Musique]
oh
avi
[Musique]